before before we move on you know what
we're talking about people embarrassing
themselves publicly the way Elon Musk
did the way Papa John did Queen
Elizabeth oh she's calling back he's
calling back into the show she's become
a great fan of our show
Queen Elizabeth all the way from the UK
are you there Queen
hello mumsy oh I forgot Prince Andrew's
here too
yeah wiped out
Oh Oh mumsy none of it's true I didn't
know it was happening
mumsy where are you calling from yeah I
can't really hear what you're saying
Queen there has to be something Queen
Elizabeth there has to be something we
can do here why have you decided to
erase Prince Andrew from all public
records boy
historical purposes legacy is more
important than any one person as he well
knew when he started didn't you believe
my interview mumsy oh my god what a
party interview apparently has caught up
now you've been erased from public but I
know mumsy you've indicated that twice
already first of all why does the Queen
of England roll her arse and second of
all second of all Queen Queen Elizabeth
you did I had heard you were actually
very supportive of Prince Andrew right
after the interview why have why the
sudden change of course another pair did
you used to live in England as a child
that's true your American accent in your
obsession my favor
are you implying that it must have been
fun to watch Sam dressed like Angus
Young being beaten by British boys yeah
what happened to Prince Andrew that was
Jim and Prince Andrew both here Jim and
Prince a juror
don't want to move out but Queen
Elizabeth when did you decide to turn
against Prince Andrew well I mean after
I realize it's bigger than him given
it's all a pack of lies right wait
Elaine comes out she'll defend me we'll
have to come out defend you Oh mumsy
it's always great to hear another home
run this was a good one it's always
great to hear from you thank you we have
two for two yeah Thank You Queen always
good to hear from Queen Elizabeth II as
I saw the Queen last night oh good and
we discussed between volunteered oh
that's great and I think it's time for
the Queen to call back I always say yeah
I always like to get an update from
question I agree all the way in the UK
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
SiriusXM attic